if you love your husband suck his right
now there was probably 30 50 people on
that boat and at all like half of us got
on our knees and we started sucking our
husbands off right and my boyfriend off
and then like all around me it was like
couples in loves going down on each
other synchronized sucking that's like
the best Church in the world
[Music]
did you participate in no not November
oh yeah nah I gotta jack off that's too
long that's a whole month what did you
ask them no not November did you do it
also a long time that's hard
I don't even try it like what's the
point of trying oh that's so long I
don't even think I could biologically do
it because I think I'll have wet dreams
we'll have to come without even jacking
it'll just come out then yeah plus my
schedule don't work like that guys that
could do wet dreams
that can do them like hey check it out
yeah yeah no they can't they wake up and
then they bust they wake up and they
bust that's pretty efficient but I'd
like to be awake during that I like to
be doing some otherworldly [ __ ] in here
you already live in a dream sorry that's
true
like in the context of me I wouldn't
want to switch and be a guy I like being
like me yeah I think with your yeah with
what I'm doing being like a girl this
world is cool yeah
York is hard yeah yeah you get access
you get to choose I have girl wrists I
try girl rigs what okay what is Riz like
Charisma Charisma oh okay okay gotcha
okay gotcha sometimes my boyfriend is
like oh it's so easy for you you just go
stand outside and then people are like
please [ __ ] me and I'm like no I'm just
I feel like a lot of I feel like I get
rejected more than people think but
you're shooting a lot of shots right I
don't I feel like no I'm actually pretty
picky about my shots because again it's
I have to be really specific about the
the battles I want to create and being
like get tested and [ __ ] so I feel like
so I feel like
like a lot of guys will like be like ew
no and I'll be like okay
okay like when that guy didn't want to
kiss me I was like okay I guess that's
crazy to me yeah I feel like sometimes
the sexual history is kind of gross to
the normal guy yeah yeah if you're like
brutish it's like it's it's it's fair
but it's also like uh if you're pretty
like um like honest about it and you're
you're sitting yourself all out there
in the test and all those things and
it's like all right cool then I'm with
it I [ __ ] with it yeah I know I forgot
there's guys like that out if you're
like sketchum if you're if you would say
tell me like uh I mean I just kind of
just go off Faith like I don't really
like that task yeah I'd be like that
would be like wait that'd be sucks yeah
I'm saying like no like I'm not a toxic
person like I feel like I'm just a good
little time and I feel like sometimes I
don't know like I'm not like I need
there to be equal feet like a good
feedback loop of Attraction because I'm
not gonna chase a guy I will reinforce
the same energy though like if a guy is
like into me then I'll also be vocally
into him but if he's kind of like
standing then I'm just like bro I have a
job like I got like I have other things
to [ __ ] you know you don't want to do
this yeah true yeah I feel like not
having like a dick scarcity mentality
has helped me be able to focus more
bro she's got scars you know what [ __ ]
scarcity mentality is like oh yeah it's
like I need this because I'm not gonna
get it again like it's like I'm not
gonna demean or degrade myself for dick
because it's it's an opulence it's like
it's a abundance it's everywhere it's
true for you very true sometimes that
even if we did have great sex if I feel
like you're a toxic dude I'm not dick
whipped anymore like I would have been a
Slave
but now it's like I'm a woman like I
don't care like it's not that serious
and there's just more people in the
world you know guys guys need to have
that uh as well you know to know that
like yo it's all good yo I can't [ __ ]
is an abundance if you focus on yourself
if you are a successful happy person
with yourself then [ __ ] is everywhere
but can't tell you something though know
that yeah I know that can I tell you
something yes I missed thirsting you
could still thirst just wait four days
just stop drinking water for a couple
days no like when you're too confident
like you don't you don't feel like oh I
want you so bad you know I miss that
feeling of oh I want you so so bad I
can't take it anymore yeah this is funny
adalation boner yeah and then and then I
don't I don't have that and when you're
too confident you don't want them so bad
I feel like I like there's a little bit
Cancun when I was at that swingers
resort because it was like sexy
groundhog day bro every 24 hours
away and I had 24 hours to fall in love
with you real quick and then [ __ ] so it
was like a Sprint it was just like are
we gonna do this yeah we did it and then
like the next six feet dating we could
see each other in the pool be like cool
and then I would move on to my next like
victim you know you didn't even want to
do the same person over again you'd be
like we already had it person twice
because like he was like leaving and he
was cool and like lived in some weird
state so I would definitely have some
weird State you know but like besides
that it was like I wanted the experience
of like variety yeah and it's also not
just variety because of course these
were sexual relationships but it was
like spending the whole day with someone
like I'm in The Bachelorette and like
we're like doing cool [ __ ] we're jet
skiing we're making out we're having
dinner conversations together so it's
kind of romantic and then deuces you
know and it's like something different
lives sometimes you don't need the
moment can be temporary and we're just
two people intersecting and we don't
need to keep this going because
sometimes I feel like if I get to know
you more and more and more and becomes
the whole thing oh I don't like that
what this was which was this one
beautiful night you know yeah like it
was like we were you were a cool ass
dude on vacation we did the damn thing
and I wouldn't want dancing too much
either yeah yeah and then we know and
then later you find out he complains a
lot yeah he is weird [ __ ] yeah yes we
think about that stereotype of like uh
women women get attached easier because
it's more like they're based off of
emotions and having sex and it's more
emotional chemistry all those things how
do you block that I wouldn't say a lot
of these like gender constructs are like
really generalized and when we make
these like generalized assumptions from
people we don't really know before
getting to know the individual it's more
harmful because you're not actually
getting to know that person like if we
like set up these expectations and then
don't communicate them and then but
assume those people will do it then it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy like of
course then woman would be like that I
don't but in my world I don't feel like
men or women are more predisposed to
getting feelings if we're all really
clear now if we're playing [ __ ] games
and then I'm an insecure person then I
feel like I'm more likely to be like oh
what is he doing what is he thinking
yeah what's this but it's like if we're
really clear like hey I have a partner
and I do porn this is really just the
thing I want to do because it's fun then
it's like we have managed expectations
about what this is that's great yeah I
appreciate you go you are this
that's happened to me one time where
like it was like a very like you know
beautiful moment yo like a beautiful
night with this girl and we danced we
met off of like uh from like an acting
class and then like we went out and
danced this last night and came home
drinking wine it was beautiful I had the
beautiful sex too and I was like damn
this is [ __ ] tight yo afterwards I
walk around to her car and she tells me
she's like hey I just want to let you
know um You probably we're probably not
gonna you said what like I used to yeah
pretty much like we're probably not
gonna see each other again after this
like I don't wanna I don't wanna and I
think it's much sure because sometimes
did that break your heart yo that was
this was actually the first time like uh
that like my ego it's like a wake-up
call yeah yeah because because she and
she even said like she was like uh
because she knew I'm Puerto Rican and
Dominican so she was like I get to put
that on my board of like I I banged a
Puerto Rican
she likes banging like different you
know she's like you she's trying to
connect a un U.N of sex yeah yeah so so
she so I gave her like a three for one
you know say Puerto Rico Dominican
Mexico so she could like but she but the
thing was is like uh I I was that that
really like damn you could like you
could just it could that could it could
just happen it's just like sometimes
like I think that would break my heart
but did you feel like I actually wanted
something with you man what did you feel
like that never happened before well
honestly I thought if she didn't say
that it could have like been like unsaid
and we could have just like oh that
could have been a cool build for one
night stand but the fact that she said
it and just in person like just right
there was like Hey tonight was cool but
it ain't yo that's respect that she
knows that she really meant that [ __ ] yo
like I still to this day bro I don't
know her Instagram I don't know her
Facebook I don't know her number like
she really like ghost Pro she's in here
that experience
rent free knowing more and more about
them it's like sometimes it's not
necessary like if you wanted a sexual
experience and you got it you know we
didn't want a relationship we don't have
to rationalize getting to know each
other like let's just have this moment
and then we intersect it and then we
move on and I think a lot of people try
to prolong this experience because they
are scared it's never going to happen
again but it'll happen throughout your
life yeah put scarcity let's see
scarcity yeah if you do if you keep
chasing it then you'll keep like you'll
you keep [ __ ] things so they are
destroyed you know what I mean like some
things are on purpose like my partner
and I like that's on purpose but like
some of these things are just moments
and they don't have to demean me or add
value they're just moments I think I
fall in love too fast I can't be [ __ ]
around I think I fall in love all the
time but it's a very controlled sense
that's too crazy because you said I have
24 hours to fall in love I was like okay
so then how do you like cut that thing
you know like I like establishing that
chemistry and passion and then being
like
you know I think you should go to one of
those things man dude it's a [ __ ]
blast okay so it sounds pretty
interesting but I wouldn't want to go
with somebody like who who knows the
game like show you around me I don't
want to go like green like it's just me
by yourself no you should always go for
girl it's easier to win that situation
but yo you're falling in a little bit
too much right now okay so you know you
got a bunch of dicks around you
you know the etiquette you might just
walk in and start saying who wants them
oh awesome that is the sexiest thing you
can do my partner and I we went on an
orgy boat it was she was gorgeous but
like we were kind of like huh like we're
on a boat right in the middle of the
ocean and at some point the announcer
was like if you love your husband suck
his dick right now there was probably 30
50 people on that boat and at all like
half of us got on our knees and we
started sucking our husbands off right
and my boyfriend off and then like all
around me it was like couples and loves
going down like everyone was like
synchronized sucking we're synchronized
Origins dude my boyfriend was dabbing
people up being like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of tight yeah that's like
the best Church in the world
butt ass naked I was like what's going
on look at your neighbor give him head
you have your girl and then they all we
all like got eaten out like what yeah
that's crazy
just like we were with our partner so it
was kind of romantic can I tell you
another thing okay why do you say it
like that because I need to because I
need you to um it's validate me I need
to explain okay because you you're the
closest thing to someone that I know
that has experience in this field right
so like so like I um so like for Hannah
like she she's she's someone that I love
is that your woman yes and then so I
don't care if she has as many
girlfriends as she wants it doesn't
bother me but no guys allowed why do you
think that is no PPS no PP allowed you
may not feel threatened by like woman I
guess I feel like oh yeah let's join but
if you don't want me around that's cool
too yeah you know it's funny I hate
[ __ ] with couples because I don't
like people on Opps which is what you
are what's OPP one penis policy no we're
here for equal rights baby if you I'm
only one penis my penis no I there was
like so many couples at that Resort and
they were like please [ __ ] my husband
and I'd be like are you [ __ ] with me
and I'd be like yeah I'm bisexual and
I'd be like nail check bro if your nails
are this long you are not because why
you're not finger banging girls yo
I'm for everybody
it makes sense I've learned so much [ __ ]
if your nails are this long you are
straight as [ __ ] I'm bisexual too look
there was a night where um my boyfriend
at the time my boyfriend was like he
wanted to [ __ ] this girl and this other
girl but they were related so they were
weird so he was like can I please [ __ ]
in our hotel room and I was like for
sure I'm gonna just go hotel room the
hotel room being like a human flashlight
Etc and at like 5 a.m I'm like
bro like come on like no response I
don't know if these balls deep in this
chick and I just kind of was like I'm
sleepy like what and I knew I was
different because at some point I just
like barged in and I saw my boyfriend
booty ass butt cheek naked hot dogs in a
bun condom still on the penis holding
this like random woman like naked like
tight and in my mind I was like man the
average woman would be like
well in my mind I also just like sucked
off like hella sausage meat bro so in my
mind I was just like I'm really sorry
but it's six a.m and I just need to
sleep in my bed wow y'all can sleep in
wet spots but just you gotta go bro and
my boyfriend was like I can't believe
you saw me like that I was like I don't
really care
my guy completely bitchless like what
the [ __ ] like damn yo clip that like if
you are completely bitchless you are not
my boyfriend like you need like not that
I need him to be around at her woman but
I like the outside validation that other
women think he's sexy because I'm like I
made a good choice here but what if I
went the other way around would he be
able to walk in and then you're being
cuddled by a man and he's all like bro
can you move over so I could sleep oh if
it was like love what I'm saying that's
the difference it's like
um he was like yeah I wouldn't really
care but he was like if I was caught
into me like so my boyfriend has run
trains with me like we've done orgies
together but he doesn't really like to
because I get loud and into it and he's
like
yeah you made a different noise with him
hey what did you do right time yeah yeah
how you do that like if a bro make me
squirt I know because my boyfriend and I
haven't really figured it out yet he'll
be like
you know but it's not like in like a
jealous way like I don't want you to
have that experience it's just like that
[ __ ] is cool but he has to reach that
level and he's like damn it I haven't
got to that level
for me I feel compassion like I feel
happy and my partner is experiencing fun
[ __ ] like whether he's going to a
football game or if he's getting double
teamed by like two shorties of bbl's
whatever the [ __ ] that's got nothing to
do with me you know because at the end
of the day we converge and we debrief at
the end of the night and then we like
talk about it and it's like you're
sharing it think about it you and your
best friend you guys probably talk about
the insane [ __ ] you do and it's like me
and my boyfriend have like the craziest
stories but together yeah separate and
then we're able to share it and exchange
like what we like and don't like about
each other and then like have sex with
the knowledge you know things we can't
try
what uh like other demographics of women
like do you see in these parties like
racially or like yeah racially yeah I
would say it's like it's pretty diverse
when I first started I was like I had a
lot of Asian friends there was a lot of
Asian women but it's like whatever
Circle you go to
um it's it's pretty diverse like I would
say in Cancun obviously it was a lot of
like Hispanic and white and black
because they were traveling from the
states here for the party yeah for the
party and then like when I was in Berlin
obviously hello European or something oh
got you okay yeah I remember I was in a
sex club in London and they they they
like kept making fun of my American
accent and I kept being like say
literally literally that's literally
like they're like just say things in
your American Valley Girl accent and I
was like I barely have a family that's
how they're getting off okay but we do
to them when they're here
I say literally literally
yeah that's hilarious but like we
sometimes go to sex parties and we don't
[ __ ] other people like I just like
that's better to me than You're Gone
without having sex at all no like I just
like being around like I don't like
normal clubs they're loud and I don't
know how to dance and my ass is fake so
I don't know how to twerk but I got a
fat ass so people ask me to twerk and
it's just very embarrassing so I just
like I like lounges like I like sitting
like talking well so you like when
someone's getting sucked off right next
to you and you just drinking and you're
having a conversation and you get to
look at it and you go that's nice that's
what world peace looks like yeah yeah
but it's like Fair argument it's not I
think so too it's like the sex isn't the
objective but it's friendly towards it
it's like if it happens like whatever
bro but it's like like for me I've
actually never met someone at a normal
club and then brought them to my house I
think it's really weird like I like my
Social Security's there bro like my
[ __ ] my my furry porn is there I
don't want you to see I don't know you
but how about a hotel because I've done
that that's okay but like I wouldn't
bring you to my house and I wouldn't go
to your house because I'm like lit like
that's kind of weird to me like I would
rather like I go to my friend's party
meet a guy [ __ ] him on the couch in
front of the homies and then like sex
isn't the objective then I'm just
chilling if they're homies you know like
it's like the party keeps going instead
of like oh and now I left the party to
[ __ ] this guy it was five minutes it
sucked like what like that like now it's
not the goal or the climax of my night
it's just a thing that happens it's just
a feature but then now you get to stay
at the party and be with your friends
yeah [ __ ] Costco chicken
get the Hibachi yo does your boyfriend
have to get uh tested as much as you get
tested he doesn't have to get tested as
much because like he isn't as sexually
active but like if he were to like if a
girl were to like sometimes girls will
message him and be like can you like
just stun [ __ ] it like can you just like
[ __ ] me for this video then of course he
would get oh he's into he's in the
community now is it because of you like
adjacent like he like obviously has
videos of me and my friends so like he
has like a small like social media
presence but like he's like an
attractive guy so I think like sometimes
people are like can we just like [ __ ]
and I'll [ __ ] pay you or whatever and
then he'll do and they trust him already
yeah yeah so if it's not only fans but
like let's just say he's hitting on
girls on DMS because he wants some
something else or whatever is there
protocol between two of Life yeah so we
have have um I don't have raw sex off
camera so like and so the same rules
apply so like I wouldn't he wouldn't be
having raw sex with this person and I
always say like if it's a normal person
I mean you should be getting tested bro
like in general you don't have to do it
every five to seven days because that
shit's expensive and crazy but you
should regularly get tested for your own
like Vibe for your own situation sure
yeah and then we have a fluid Bond so I
don't do cream pies I don't do facials
um and I don't call anyone Daddy because
that's awkward you know I don't get it
for you like you don't like it that just
like sucks like I don't know I just feel
like why would I call this random dude
Daddy it's like so embarrassing I'll
call you something else like like Peter
Mr Mister Mister
father
grandpa yeah Lola Lola
and then like obviously they just have
to be aware that I have a partner and I
and from there I can kind of feel out
like if they get it or not because
sometimes like I could feel like some
guys like think I'm lying and they think
I'm just cheating on my boyfriend and
I'm like nah bro like my boyfriend knows
what I'm doing they're just in disbelief
like some guys do yeah
well guys always like hey I'm in an open
relationship but it was kind of
interesting like I was in Cancun and I
was [ __ ] this guy and I my phone
started ringing and obviously it's my
boyfriend and it's like I'm just he
knows what I'm doing so I don't care and
the guy was like
you should answer that and I was like
for like I was like yeah like he thought
I was being sus and I was like no I'm
actually not being assessed in this
world it's actually very unsus yeah
unsus I mean that's more that's more
rare to come by yeah yeah he was like
answer that bro I was like we're good he
had an experience where it was that
which one remember when that dude came
barging in while you were with that girl
you had to hide in the other room yeah
it was a whole situation oh my God
what's the team more often now oh man
check out episode
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign